[Music]
just feel it that weight and of flows
that voice you hear is Pat McAfee Pat
that sound you hear one of our amazing
homies rod Simba the listeners made this
song got in the studio got some
instruments made sani so you know wise
man left coke could use some sensual
beats to kick off of shown here we are
just vibing to some sensual beats from
Oh cozy
batt McAfee is just off a bus fresh off
a bus going cross country on your way to
Wrestlemania row dress how do you feel I
feel okay I think I was built for life
on the road oh you would have been you
know you'd have been like the best
roadie or rockstar whichever you would
have portrayed I was a partner put me
behind the drums or the triangle but the
the road is that my dad was a truck
driver Wow so whenever I was a teen the
early teen you're maybe like right
before that I I've driven like an
18-wheeler whenever I was did not have a
license so I can float them gears a
little bit and I got a chance to do it
with this RV I felt pretty good driving
through the cities Baltimore DC we're
doing a thing how much part of your
childhood did you think you were gonna
drive trucks I mean it was definitely a
viable option all the way up until Bill
Polian drafted me I mean that was
definitely a fallback place my dad did
refrigeration and air conditioning and I
thought every kid when they grew up got
a van and they had to wash their hands
with that orange [ __ ] soap like I
thought that was just part of life and
then I was like oh I could just talk and
this could be my life I still think you
should wash your hands with that orange
soap though I mean that thing really
gets the job done and I walk to the
toilets in here and bleach report you
should get some of that orange soap
around everywhere somebody just I mean
somebody plowed through one of them
toilets over here but bleach reports a
nice place this is incredible thing sure
you dig it I love it here it's honest as
good as your indie compound I mean we
have a we have a much larger basketball
court than you guys you do you guys it
seems like you guys got like a gimmick
court here just so you can shoot some
stuff if you have to shoot some stuff
sounds good our court gets used on a
very regular basic aliy the epicenter of
our office that's that in like probably
ten to twenty million dollars more worth
of tech here that's really the big
difference is huge yeah little things
works
this place is incredible so what I'm
knowing amazed by you is I'm getting
ready to host the match and I'm talking
to someone that's like high ranking like
you know we're looking for like some
some Pat McAfee types to come and get
more attention and I go what do you mean
by Pat McAfee type so like you know like
he's kind of like his own media company
and like people care about what he says
and I go there ain't other [ __ ]
that are doing this guy like that's
what's so crazy about your situation is
we all saw the path the early retirement
with the barstool announcement and you
kind of built it up in the heartland and
we saw the interns coming in and now
it's just [ __ ] you and it's got to
feel freeing and also crazy at the same
time yeah we have no idea what's going
on I was very lucky that barstool kind
of took me in and taught me the business
of the Internet right out of because
when I retired I had like a pseudo agent
okay I'd think about retiring like two
years before I retired I was fed up with
that was just done with it I was I was
done with the NFL routine I didn't know
love going to work right
and I watched my dad go to work for a
long time and my dad didn't enjoy it I
was like if I ever get to the point
where I hate going to work I'm gonna
change it right so I made enough money
with the NFL I got a chance to take care
of my family got chance take care of my
friends got everybody out of debt hit
the reset button let's go now we just
got to keep the lights on let's enjoy
this life so I thought about retiring a
couple years in advance and then Chuck
Pagano talked me into it on a USO trip
he's like let's go we went to Japan were
17 hours within six inches of each other
so we had a lot of conversations or
lights on in my office Pat Lea listen
Pat you can't just retire right now
we've still got a couple more years to
do this Shing knowing maybe another
Super Bowl maybe another Pro Bowl what
do you say let's go and now he's a cool
guy cool guy yeah and now we had 16 and
a half more hours to go so I mean it was
it was a long flight to Japan he talked
me to coming back a couple times it was
just it was one of those things where I
was I didn't enjoy working where I was
working anymore so I had like the pseudo
agent a guy that was kind of connected
to me I didn't have an agent before that
and he was a TV guy and I sent him a
text I'm like hey I got your number from
OCO people they said you're a good
connected the plug you know he's like
that's very nice of them what can I help
you with I was like well my name is Pat
bag fee uh I my punt balls for a living
so when the offense fails I come out do
my thing yeah not very much
at the home stadium because it means
they're often Stern a ball over away
games oh I get a big pop like people
love when I come on the fear no I do
pretty good on the Internet I was
wondering if I was to retire after this
season I'm gonna make the Pro Bowl if I
make another Pro Bowl be like two-time
Pro Bowl or you know I have a pretty
good little following on the Internet I
understand my job my position isn't a
very important one but you were
self-aware really yeah I understood I
was like but I do pretty good on the
internet and you put me on a microphone
I'm pretty good I was like do you think
any TV networks would want to just bring
me in or have me do anything he was like
oh let me check I'll get back to you he
sent me a text back twenty two minutes
later and said there is zero interest
from any TV no Wow zero interest like he
it was a I thought it was like maybe
he'll sleep on it like I reach out to
some people even have a snack so it was
like he sent out like it maybe a group
text to hold the networks it seemed like
he had him just on a group tag one
person said no he said okay I'll get
back-to-back yeah so no I think they all
prior just like nope nope nope what the
[ __ ] up at McAfee I nope alright so I
didn't really know what I was gonna do I
was gonna start my own app I was gonna
start my own app in Indy cuz I had a
nice following and I did a couple
stand-up comedy tours sold a lot of
tickets did a lot of good stuff right we
sold like 10,000 tickets for a stand-up
comedy tour and 36 minutes or something
I guess that's why yeah I rented out the
theaters I sold the tickets myself it
was so the whole time are you like I
know there's something here yeah there
was a I was like making a lot of money
doing those things so I was like you
know what I hit the reset button for
everybody I'm not enjoying punting balls
on fourth downs anymore I'm not enjoying
it and I just wanted to see if there was
a way cuz I don't wanna be dumbass and
give up all the money right out I come
from a working-class family
money's a big deal for freedom he
doesn't bring you happiness but don't
bring a lot of freedom for sure
so I was gonna start building my own app
with a guy named Tom McComas who was 21
years state police officer he owned a
stand-up comedy club was a stand-up
comedian and he was like [ __ ] it I'll
join you I'm not enjoying going to work
anymore either so he retired I would
start we're gonna start our own happened
and Portnoy called me and was like hey
we just want to help kind of facilitate
everything you're doing teach you the
ropes I was like my man thank you so I I
still got to run my own thing in
Indianapolis with Barstow Heartland
still got to watch how the business
works and I felt like how Leba tarde is
with ESPN or how like pardon the
interruption is with ESPN where it's
like this offshoot where like you're
under the umbrella but you're an
independent entity it felt clean
it was a very nice I didn't want to
leave indeed cuz I love Indianapolis I
got a good Network out there I mean I I
love my I love Indianapolis I very met
your fiancé yeah yeah got all wiped up
Thank You man forevers a long time yeah
long time it's a long time it was a good
decision though it was a bit ah I'm
gonna hear this and I'm gonna get fought
at the house but so Dave just wanted to
facilitate everything I got chance to
learn a lot from them and it just came
time where me being seven her miles away
was difficult so we weren't kind of solo
dolo and it's just me and my boys now
just great and stuff on the internet
having a good time but it's has not
slowed down for a second no yeah we keep
it going
I'm a bit of a nancy person so I want
everything like like the other day I
woke up this is how dumb our office is
the other day I woke up I went in there
the boys are there we're shootin hoops
I'm like yeah I want to write a movie
today so we literally just grabbed some
vitamins we sat in a circle in the
middle of basketball quite immense our
daddy cigars to our to my homies yeah
yeah daddy's old Rob because he had made
the beats he's probably on a lot of
vitamins Isis chill but yeah we and we
wrote a movie so we'll probably film a
movie and it's just like every day I get
to wake up go to work with my friends
and just kind of figure out what we're
gonna do it a scheme make some more
money yeah I find all these guys that
you brought here today so the team of
the crew yeah me like five dudes we came
fresh out of the RV bro the road Hawks
is walk over just the door open and
they're just billowing smoke that's how
I wish hey I wish you gotta be smart
though like I work with the WWE so I
can't be getting arrested on the road
correct you know what I mean I think
that's good for their brain I know it's
probably good for mine I don't know so
I'm trying to be respectful but yeah I
got a guy from Boston he's very loud he
just makes content he came in as an
intern whenever we first started the
show hurting I got a guy from Michigan
who's very handsome he took a trip to
Miami like a month and a half go it's
become a whole new guy he's my editor
he's my right-hand guy of him Fox he's
with everywhere I go I got a friend from
back home big Italian guy Nick he quit
his job the same night I retired and
said I like I'll join him he's been my
friend since like high school I got a
couple other views yeah I mean we got
his gun I'm sensing a trend it's a bunch
of dudes they got fed up with [ __ ]
and said let's just do our own stuff we
got a guy named Zito now this dude was
building telephone poles
in Chicago and once you meet him you can
quickly realize that the telephone pole
system in Chicago is probably [ __ ]
because he is one of the most electric
humans of all time and we got a guy from
Iowa who got accepted to Harvard and
decided not to go he went to Iowa
instead he had it's my all of the
audience you're living in India when all
these TV people are like New York LA
Miami
they're like Indianapolis well what I'm
thinking is on the internet clicks or
clicks man maybe if somebody wants to
find you they'll find you no matter
where you're a hundred percent and I
love your studio here this video is
incredible if every studio in New York I
looked like this is insane I'd be very
tempted to travel to one of the larger
cities but I mean Indy we got a nice
thing set up it's nowhere near this nice
but not a lot of places are so what I'm
learning before we I bring in I have
some stuff that I want to go to let's go
what do you how do you think you see the
internet that other people don't see it
that gives you an advantage um I just
think so I'm very lucky that I have a
very basic palate okay so if I like
something there's probably a good chance
that a lot of people do I'm just a basic
ass [ __ ]
every when it comes down to it if I
think that drink is good there's
probably a good chance a lot of people
are gonna think it's good if I think
some food is good there's probably a
good chance a lot of people who think
I'm a very basic dude and I was very
self-aware from a very long time like
you know I'm the most average dude
average you're not swishing the wine on
the table and act you can smack like the
berries like I feel like I'm a pretty
relatable human I think whenever I got
in the NFL and I got arrested obviously
October 22 2010 Twitter became my means
to like let people know like yeah I
obviously was very intoxicated but I'm
not a full-blown idiot and I think it
became just like a community of people
that are like if we had a friend or a
brother in the NFL we would think it
would be this guy cuz he's a [ __ ] he's
average he just so happens to have a
rocket launcher as a right leg and that
was that's kind of what it is and I
think I think I'm not scared to say some
things that most people were thinking
yeah I don't ever want to be
controversial because I like to sleep at
night you know but I'm not scared to I'm
very confident in my opinions because
I've come to realize that a lot of
people probably agree with them and that
there is a difference speaking your mind
and not saying controversial things as
possible yeah
is I don't like some people feel like
they need to go for the moon hey listen
to the I thought about doing this we we
had some daddy cigars and start talking
thank you I want to do a documentary
where it would be a rough couple months
but I get a chance to go in a lot of
shows nowadays right you do cuz I got an
agent and also because nobody has hired
me full-time so I'm allowed to go
wherever I want so we're just for my own
brain
you have your own podcast yeah pimp it
out pack your shows 2.0 it's average I
mean it's good it's average though okay
you're doing stuff with the WWE oh yeah
what else you got going like you're
doing like a million things no I mean
Heartland radio 2.0 is another show okay
that comes out of our office you know
we're becoming a little empire they're
just small business trying to do big
they don't worry about them and indeed
they're just gonna come up and slash
your throat when you're sleeping that's
how I feel now well hug you guys but
we're gonna do a stand-up comedy tour
we've got a lot of stuff going on yeah
I'm just trying to cook as much as
possible just trying to cook cuz trying
to have a good time but I don't like
we're gonna make a documentary though
where we openly decide that I'm just
gonna start sawing people down like
become a hot take machine so that I
would get a look from like ESPN or like
from Fox or from Bleacher Report's just
become like or one of these bigger
entities but it would be hard for me to
sleep at night for those two months like
if I just came out so sawing people down
and I'll get us my idea why didn't I
don't show in a week I would get a
national show him probably two weeks
when Syd was left I joked I was like
what if I changed my name to right Co
and I'm always right
and I'm just anybody I just go what's
the biggest takeaway day I'm going the
opposite and those humans make us a lot
of money in this business a lot of money
in this business I'm realized because I
have agents now it's a very interesting
scene when I walk into this place it's a
lot of suits obviously it's not really
my thing bunch of yuppies everywhere but
they're kind of like introducing me to
people you know and all these dum-dums
that I'm talking to these things like
they did they don't get it they don't
get what I am they don't understand it
and then I watch the people that they
hire and these people can't even like do
anything that they're being hired for
and I'm like you dum-dum yeah bunch of
dump them so it's inspiring by the way
when you see dumb people succeed you're
a lot like so I've been able to hang out
with Barkley a lot lately and just like
going down at
turbo Tori's the greatest Harry pet but
he he's amazing because he is who he is
and everyone just had to adapt and
that's what I see like you're gonna walk
in sleeves off and you go everyone that
was in that room will never think that
I'm showing up in a suit with my hair
combed back ready to do the news I don't
have to worry about that ever but a lot
of people I just want to be in that room
I'll do whatever it takes and that's a
suffocating life well I mean that's why
you you quit well whenever it's asked
was where I retired I turned down a very
large check right a very large check and
it just got to the point where I was
like man I don't enjoy doing this and
there was a couple times where I had to
go gladdy and some people you know what
some of these networks they're like you
got to put a suit on or whatever and I
put a suit on and I like I almost
started like attacking myself you know I
was almost like yo like do you not have
any soul bro you're gonna go try to sell
out for these people and it turns out it
didn't work anyways I should have walked
in there with some shorts on I just told
about exactly how I felt I'd say I'm not
saying the homeys that that's how you
should approach job interviews but like
if you fake it when you first meet your
boss you're gonna have to fake it the
rest of your time you're catfishing yes
you're catfishing them you're and you're
stuck yes so I am very much a I am me
all the time and it's a I'm very lucky
to do so all right so I have six things
for you that I find fun I don't like to
lead the show when someone cools on I
just want you to tell us where we're
going
so that's right Co so I got one two
three four five and six they're all
different topics and different things
don't try and look through just how many
are we doing there's literally six there
are we doing all six all six
oh just we'll start with one then okay
number one I'll let you read it I don't
remember what I put in there yes Tom
Dempsey's foot okay I have been amazed
all right about Tom Dempsey for my
entire life all right for people that do
not know Tom Dempsey who is a kicker
that had for a long time the longest
kick in the history of the NFL he's 63
yards it was later passed by Matt Prater
tied a few times David Akers Jason Elam
I think had it he was born with no
fingers on one hand and no toes on the
other
and I have always been amazed at this
swinging club and I just want to know
from your perspective like why is this
not talked about more like this thing is
crazy well it's because he's a kicker of
punter man that's just the way it goes I
mean you big wigs at these big networks
just quarterbacks only that's it I mean
Sims is just assumes guys wherever he
wants and he was what a fourth string
quarterback for a while I mean Esposito
was a quarterback I mean it's Tom
Dempsey is an OG in the for the brand
you know super for the brand it's one of
those things where you see those videos
on the internet where kids got one arm
or something but he's a pitcher in
baseball because his entire life he was
told that he can't do it yeah I'm
assuming Tom Dempsey was said told like
ok here's the deal I can't do anything
with your feet have you looked at
pictures of it oh yeah with the boot he
had to boot to they made him a special
boot that some people would argue that
there was potentially a little unfair a
little home cookin in here Tom Dempsey
replied when people said it was unfair
unfair a how about you and I guess he's
Canadian how about you try kicking a
63-yard field goal to win it with two
seconds left and you're wearing a square
shoe oh yeah and you don't have toes the
amount that's that's what he responded
to now sports science looked into it and
found that the the shoe had no advantage
that it actually might be a disadvantage
because it's just a flat surface oh yeah
that sports science guys always bomb
John Brenkus sports science he compared
to white for any spin move to that of a
figure skater an Olympic figure skater
and Dwight Freeney guy you don't want to
make fun of a lot you know but we're all
looking forward to Dwight Freeney sports
science right yeah it was the night he
came out on a Saturday night so Sunday
morning was like breakfast before a game
and every we're all like yell for any
sports science coming out tonight coming
out tonight it'll be a freaky spin move
that in the next morning like the way
that guy described the dominance of
Dwight Freddy was just like some of the
most ridiculous metaphors of all time
and free to the next born gallivanting
around the field like a Olympic figure
skater or something like ballerinas and
figure skaters so the next morning like
we all walked in and I was over too
young so I could have really just
started talking but all freedom was like
was like don't you want to talk about it
don't even want to talk about it like
let's just guys let's just move on from
the sports science thing so I'm not the
biggest
fan of that guy but yeah I don't to kick
a ball 63 yards you have to have some
real explosion like that's real work
that not everybody can do that and I
didn't know this in 77 they started a
Tom Dempsey rule that if you have
something wrong with your foot it still
has to be shaped like a foot so you
can't even do the boot anymore what if
they would have put a plow right like a
plow right there on the front like it's
in the front of a truck stead of
Vinatieri picking up the snow he's just
plowing out the [ __ ] snow I'm a I'm a
Dempsey fan I was gonna I'm just curious
from like the kicking you know the
physics not having toes seems crazy to
me I'm not sure how much the toes how
about you they tell you to point your
toes so I guess that is a massive part
of it but the the opposable thumb right
is pretty massive for the human so I
write them that the big toe also does
some work in the kicking world nice
shout-out Tom Dempsey though overcoming
some adversity to become a G all the
time which number we going with next for
Vinatieri all-time leading scorer you
love that man so much I mean I was he's
good dude he's Italian so that's kind of
against them did you guys ever have a
fight we got into it one time he
compared me to Vanderjagt to a special
teams coach and it was like in warmups
he was like he's got a little Vanderjagt
in him dying right in front me I looked
at him I was like don't you ever don't
you hey don't you ever do that again
what is wrong with Vanderjagt idiot
kicker from Peyton Manning I don't know
he was at West Virginia though for me I
didn't know that he was a West Virginia
before me was that the quotes before me
and I know that it ended bad with quotes
but even at West Virginia I've never
heard like a positive story about like
there's no there's not a lot for Payton
to go on national TV and go he's an
idiot
that kicker got liquored up yeah like
Payton never puts that [ __ ] out there
now in it was tough because I got a an
intoxication so obviously because I went
to West Virginia and I was a person to
kick the balls are you secretly
Vanderjagt no I are you the titty boy
turned into to chase they just give you
are you Vantage out with a new name
Vanderjagt did a lot of good things with
footballs but from what I've heard his
teammates never liked him and that was a
huge part for me it was a huge thing for
people like teammates Co pretend to well
yeah all right okay I don't care how
they like I don't know I keep wanting to
open this
you open it okay plan Jim Irsay 60th
birthday party let's make it to there
Jim June 13th is his 60th birthday
you know this man well if he said and
you could do it in his voice
yeah I want you to plan my birthday what
are we doing brother from Bloomington
have them do it I'll bring my guitar I'm
like all right Jim I like that well
brick will get Mellencamp up there he's
just you know born and raised a small
town or whatever he was yeah I like camp
what else would you like Jim well six
decades that's maybe we get McCartney to
play with guitar right-handed whoa right
who woulda thought I made it to 60 who
woulda thought Paul would play right
here have you ever heard the conspiracy
dude that Paul McCartney is in Paul
McCartney it's another guy cuz Paul
McCartney died like 30 years ago I
haven't heard that Jim well you should
think about it they'll be a good party
now let's bring the Horseshoe out there
and a little the motorcycle Trek thing
that comes out before the game I love
that guy you got it Jimmy anything else
maybe a couple golf loose I love golf
let's golf maybe let's do it Jim let's
have a happy birthday you want to sing
it you want us to sing happy birthday or
blow your candles out for it blow the
candles out on or a fire maybe we just
jump in the cake we'll jump out of it
maybe we have baton Manning jump out of
the cake
that's what would do it would build him
a statue that's at least he could
[ __ ] ghetto brothers jump out of a
cake
anything else nobody good just a run on
huh
that was good you spent a lot of time
with this man not really not really not
really I don't think a lot of people who
spent a lot of time with Jimerson really
to be honored party with Jim Irsay no
I'm passed Jim Mercy's party time I
wasn't sure though if he still parties
but doesn't get down so he doesn't I
know he doesn't drink like a lot of
course a lot of people anytime he does
anything anything at all like the
internet obviously is a woke society
film savages so anytime Jim Irsay does
anything I owe a lot to Jim Irsay
thing almost I actually do Oh every
every Jim Irsay
but he's he's got a heart of gold man
but his brain once it gets going and
woohoo and he's got about to have sixty
years worth of incredible stories he
needs to like a Jim Irsay podcast where
it's one story every podcast he does
like those press things every once in a
while there'll be like four media people
I come into his office it's one question
look man you won't hold Europe got that
thing stretched out and that's what when
he called Quinton Nelson he's like hey
Quinton what's up man and then like the
next three minutes are Quinton I saw
Anthony muñoz and I gotta tell you about
muñoz and like Quinton and I asked
couldn't he's like I'm only on the phone
I'm just listening but it's like to
Quinton talk to you that's crazy yeah
quitting's my guy I quit I'm gonna
threaten fight me baby well the thing
you can't do with Quinton Nelson is give
him all the credit he's a [ __ ]
offensive lineman they do not want the
credit because they don't want to walk
in there and look at Costanzo and go hey
man
yeah I'm friends we get along cuz he
went to Boston College yeah Braniac so
as much as Anthony Costanzo and I can be
friends I feel like we get along pretty
well right Quinton Nelson has helped in
everything Costanzo out a lot too so I'm
right there but I think Quinton doesn't
want anyone to go to him and go you're
the reason the offensive lines better
well if he's an offensive lineman's like
we're a team I respect that's why I love
quit and I respected yeah he's the
ultimate like wingman he's an incredible
football player to incredible football
player pick another one yeah let's go
with number five Pat white best Colts
prank yes I'm not a big prankster not
saying you I was really curious about a
Payton prank to anybody and you saw it
or was there any single one in that
locker room where somebody got God's
okay okay so I won't say exact names but
I will say if there was an Illuminati on
the team who the Illuminati of the team
so the collection of the team if that
makes sense we just talked about this so
like the hot everybody assumes the
Illuminati is just the higher-ups of
society right right and they're all
working together to control us and
stuff it's been on my bucket list since
I'm like 11 years old to get asked to
join the Illuminati I thought I was
gonna be a part of the Illuminati when
he came here when he came here no when
when you came when I me and my girl now
my fiancee went today
gradually look at you thanks bro I don't
want to steal your shine earlier I let
you do your whole thing it was great you
forevers a long time so we go to this
jay-z concert and we're [ __ ] zooted
and he looks out and my girl has an old
rockefeller jacket and I held it up and
he goes and he goes where's that
[ __ ] with a Rockefeller jacket
and the entire crowd moved away from us
here yo Illuminati like the beam coming
down third I thought we were gonna get
sucked up from last I'm pretty sure I
looked at my girl and said we're gonna
have brunch with Beyonce and I thought
it was our time but here II just said
mosh around that guy so it turned so you
actually got abused
yeah is hard to get [ __ ] tough alright
so just get your ass kicked by a bunch
of T no because it's like people at a
jay-z show they're like don't smudge my
[ __ ] Jordan okay stay away from oh is
that jay-z's demo yeah they probably
charge like 200 bucks unnecessary that's
a lot that's like Justin Timberlake just
sold out Bankers Life in Indiana on a
Tuesday just one of two strata twos
going up probably made like 10 million
on a Tuesday cause the loser like I
think the [ __ ] dance and open his
shirt I don't even get dance really I
was seeing a lot of videos from that
thing I think he just walked around the
circle couple of times but hey if I get
a chance to be in the same building as
Justin Timberlake I'm paying whatever
the [ __ ] he's charging me I'll tell you
that it's got style ins I was an
innocent guy too
I don't know for sure yeah I think
everybody with a brain was I liked Brian
was he in Bleacher know he was in
Backstreet Boys he was in the bleachers
truth booth yeah you got a really nice
studio and she the worst [ __ ] band
ever
basketball football you know soccer or a
house of highlights it never stops
all right so lon the Illuminati of the
Colts prank yeah yeah okay so where are
we set the scene
so off fadd it's good for this job by
the way it's good for this job
I think ad DS good for this I think so
too I've tried the adderall it's not I
don't like what it does to my brain
machine I understand why it's a PD
though I mean I wanted to run through a
wall at one point so there's a lot of
guys that are kicking and punting with
that using a drone
yeah and it wasn't until after I left
the league that I tried out a row and I
was like yo these [ __ ] are
cheating for I can feel the laces 40
yards or whatever these dudes like diode
in me I'm like oh what's that a hot dog
for four dollars that's crazy I got a
point let's do it like that's an
interesting thing yeah alright so I was
like I think it was my second year it
was my second year yeah it's my second
year we're a training camp in the rural
training camp like the night before we
check out you don't answer a knock on
the door okay you don't answer a knock
on the door because the trick was they
would fill up a big ass one of them
garbage cans of water leaned it against
your door cuz all your stuffs packed
it's on the floor because you're
checking out the next day everybody
wants to get out of training camp so
they knock like 1:30 2:00 a.m. say if
there's an emergency you open the door
push a whole rooms drenched right yeah
so the rules were like don't ever answer
your door late and it was my second year
I was pretty woke to this finitary took
care of me the year before I was like
just don't open your door bro as I got
it so the second year second the last
night before checkout or second last day
before checkout and I got a knock on my
door at like 1:00 a.m. and I was like
nope I actually said no that's the house
the thing I'm like nope and they're like
no no come on we want you to come with
us I was like no like not doing this no
way alright yeah
ain't no sucka you know there's no way
I'm doing that and one of the members of
the Illuminati put his fingers
underneath the door it was like there's
nothing here come on like open the door
so I open it and it's it's like a very
high-end group from the cults right and
they're like let's go you're part of us
it's like all minutes of the ring hoods
and holding candles all black definitely
dressed in all black they yeah
definitely dressed in all black and I'm
like oh my it's like I didn't know who
was doing the garbage-can thing I'd
heard about it Wow and then when the
group that open the door I was like oh
it's you got like hole this is crazy
and they're like you want to come I'm
like yeah absolutely I wanna do I'm not
a big prank guy though because I like to
sleep at night so I don't like doing
those time noticing this yeah like I
like to feel a good energy guy I just
like everybody feel - hey hey everybody
good I agree I don't know where it's
gonna come back to you if you do I
believe in karma yeah I believe in karma
this particular evening though the group
had decided night
to be there that we're gonna go get a
member of like the PR staff which is in
another dorm so there's like a quad
right so the players are in one
dormitory then like the coaches staff PR
everybody is in another dorm around here
and then there's no authority so there's
a real-life quad I went to West Virginia
we didn't have a quad it was just like a
bunch of mountains hills and drunk kids
every yeah exactly so we go over in this
other building and the Illuminati had a
key fob to get in or whatever and it's
1:00 1:15 a.m.
are you excited the Illuminati pic to
you yeah jacked up jacked up and it's
all because I could chuck beer fast and
I knew that I put on a show in the off
season with a couple people I think
that's how that was your talent show to
the team your wookie year well I didn't
do a door in the team because I still
was trying to make the team but once I
had established myself in the off season
want to come Payton look yeah it
actually got to the point where Payton
was like do that thing and then there
was a time at a Texas Roadhouse where
finitary was betting on me like I was a
horse against a local like in a pitcher
it was awesome it was incredible we had
a we had a couple bonding moments so I
get invited into this group we go over
there and we take a big-ass garbage can
and it fill it up you got to go into the
showers of the dormitory so we're
filling up this thing a 1:15 a.m. I'm
the youngest so I'm obviously filling up
the thing here and everybody the
Illuminati are hiding in the different
shower stalls because we're still I mean
it's we're not supposed to be worried
right
while we're filling it up in rows
shirtless Bill Polian general manager of
Indianapolis quotes to brush his teeth a
late night brush his teeth so we all
like poked our head out like oh like
that gives a guy we should not be seeing
right
shirtless toothbrushing bill polly yeah
towel like over the shoulder he might
shave and that draft pig with buffalo 20
years ago was great man I'm lucky I
drafted Peyton's book and then Andrew
Luck write my [ __ ] lap is crazy
yeah Andrew Luck wasn't thought of yet
but I'm sure he Bill Polian
had it he knew he knew it was coming
within that AF crumbles I'm gonna be
upset in 30 years don't take the money
from the Carolina heard he's got that on
like a piece of paper like Kevin Costner
on draft day like don't take the money
from the Carolina Hurricanes owner I
[ __ ] hate that movie why ended a
relationship that I was
legit she was from Cleveland she was
obsessed at all the beauty shots of
Cleveland the movie ends I'm laughing
and I go that was the worst movie I've
ever seen in my life and she goes you're
the worst movie I've ever seen I was
like that doesn't make it was right
what yes get out of here bro awful are
you in it no I'm not in I'm like you
better be gettin residual checks to
stand up the dog pound deserves a little
positive positive pub and that's what
that was
I heard that no one showed up to his
birthday party big deal by the way let's
Scout the number one quarterback in the
draft the day before the draft when we
had the third pick I'm sorry if nobody
goes with you Barney heard that says a
lot maybe you should be a little bit
better of a football nerd if nobody goes
to the guy's birthday party there's a
reason okay get out of your Kevin
Costner dude Dances with Wolves up there
wasn't Dances with Wolves put into
drafted yeah what movie it was basically
Bull Durham right there in Cleveland I
saw dancing Bulls recently it was great
first time I've never seen it I saw I
haven't liked the same thing not it I've
heard it's the same thing all right back
to the [ __ ] bill politics Oh Bill
Polian is brushing his teeth and doing
whatever he's doing I'm filling up the
garbage can
and watching these the Illuminati of the
coats like butt pucker a little bit when
Bill Polian walked in there at 1:15 a.m.
because we're not supposed to be there
was kind of a cool moment by the way
like oh that's I think that might have
been when I realized like you everybody
poops the same like well that's Robert
Mathis reacts like that that's crazy
you're trying to find out who was in a
group Robert Mathis was not so just know
that he was ever ever ever you know the
cue dogs all have brands on him oh yeah
no he was a cute dog yeah he's not gonna
do the whole hand thing don't get a you
career of course you know what about it
my fiancee yells me want to do it don't
even throw half of that thing you will
end up half a man at that point you'll
just be Adam left
okay so Malthus was totally there
Malthus was not there so I'm filling up
the garbage can and he's in there just
taking his time so that things filled up
to the top so it sounds like somebody's
pissing into like a pond right right
around a corner from Bill Polian one of
the greatest GM's of all time I knew it
couldn't be deaf he had to hear what was
happening we get by it's all good he
ends up wandering back to his thing with
his hip or whatever so he leaves and now
the operation were still on
we have to dump out some water and we
get on this PR guy's room and I we leave
it on the door and I've never seen the
process before it is as amateur as you
would think with these people yes like
three people like trying to Lina
spilling it all over the hall you know
like just the whole situation it's just
a joke it's like a bunch of 12 year olds
again I'm not a big prank or so I was
enjoying it
I wasn't fast enough to do the knocking
on because I was partner so they had
like a wide receiver do it so they
leaned the so they lean the thing
against it Reggie waiting I've never
talked so he was definitely not a part
of it he was but by the way he shows up
your door you answered him [ __ ] you do
whatever you need to do Marvin ears and
I have talked more than yeah more than
we probably should I mean I've had
numerous conversations with Marvin
Saracen good guy great guy to me all of
question how often should you talk to
Marvin Harris all right so we're trying
to lean against so Elena thing that's
the thing and I've never been a part of
this I'm kind of excited the heart
starting array I'm like all this why
they do it like this is a real cool
moment why our serie knocks on door
right in a Sprint's to where we're at
we're in an exit door or whatever and he
goes out what all right they're like
okay we got him right they're like okay
we got him so goes back for a knock
again he's like what do what runs back
doesn't open the door like we got him on
the line it's like a fish it feels like
they're fishing like I got a couple
bottom they got a couple couple bites
real oh man so living quadri is Mel wide
receiver goes back and I don't even know
who that is why he was not a part of
this or whatever
whoever it was so he goes back Austin
Collie bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang opens the door while
he's like half a step away from the door
loud high-pitched scream of help we're
spring down the steps outside this thing
like bum bum bum bum bum bum we get all
the way out we're like there's like
laughing there's high-fiving like I've
never been a part of something like this
before I felt like I was like in a kid's
camp which I never want to so then we go
to bed we like kind of get under your
covers the lights off like you know the
whole thing wake up the next morning
outside and there's just like this
entire cleaning crew walking into their
dorm
apparently we flooded the floor and like
Jim Caldwell I called up the team and he
was like I'm not gonna ask who did it
but we have to pay for an entire new
floor I guess the water was dripping
underneath is that much water there was
too much water because because we didn't
don't thought it fill Polian teeth yeah
so Jim Cole was like yeah it was a high
pitch it echoed through the entire thing
you see the lights in the dorm like go
on and Jim Caldwell was like I don't
wanna know who it was just know that we
can't do it anymore because the quotes
have to pay for an entire new floor
basically and Jim Cole's like those guys
like if you disappoint him because he's
like guys somebody uh Jim Kowal is a
human like that's who I don't have a gym
called no I'm not saying he's bad I
really did love him but whenever he said
that I was like Jimmy you don't know who
did that because you don't get fired
before they will did you ever tell the
guy that it was you I thought you were
part of it the ER guy he probably knows
I think he came up to me like the next
day and was like good one and I'm like
why do you automatically assume that I
was a part of that
like hey this is a lot bigger than I was
but it was a lot better I didn't tell
him that day because I thought I could
potentially get cut right I wasn't good
enough at that point man be like yeah
but you were cool enough to be in the
Illuminati see that congratulations hey
man that's only a real prank I was ever
a part of it we should oh there was a
car shipped to like Montana one time
what yeah somebody just like shipped
somebody's car to Montana it happened
kid parked in a spot he should have
parked in he was just acting like he was
a big deal yeah and what was his name I
don't remember his name because he
didn't make the team like that's why it
was such a big deal and he gets shipped
to Montana yes so during practice
happened called in a shipping company
got his car shipped it to Montana yeah
so he comes out from practice it was
like some it was a terrible car this kid
just thought he was like a very big deal
yeah he was parking like like it might
have been like in some big guy spots
Satan spa yeah well Payton didn't he did
whatever he wanted but it was some
og spots and his kid was just Park in a
star like daily for like four or five
straight days he did yeah like even
after people told him
like I don't care whatever you know so
his car got shipped to Montana which is
beautiful I that was the coolest thing
I've ever seen in my town that's pretty
hell I was not a part of that planning
but that is next-level planning and it
took the kid like a week and a half ago
his car back from Montana kind of got
lost in translation out there it was
beautiful every night and a kid might I
got cut like before the car even got
back that's so like you need to get out
of town where's any kid the cars
literally out of town so I don't know
what to tell you
take another number that's also six do
to it oh yeah I'm not a big I'm not a
big prank guy though I'm Herron Lee
except you've helped ship cars to me I
was I I know I watched that happen but
the flooding of the dormitory a week
before they go back to school and had it
shut damn
some kid is [ __ ] party with one kicker
yes and there's three names on sea bass
Matt Prater Jeffrey okay sea bass I feel
like is the the mystery guy in all the
NFL I feel like everybody wants to know
sea bass stories Matt Prater I've heard
gets lit he doesn't lit I've heard the
same stories probably Jeff Reed I've
only seen the pictures of him with
Pittsburgh with just Google Jeffrey and
his blonde as hair with no shirt on at a
party he had the Pauly D blowout way
before Holly be I am tan Reid
yeah have you partied with any of those
guys already I've partied with Jeff Reed
I was in college
what was he in the same College as you
now he's Pittsburgh Steeler I'm from
Pittsburgh so Wow he talks [ __ ] on me
actually he didn't know I was in the
group he talks [ __ ] on me like one of my
friends like what do you think about
McAfee this is why we're like probably
ten beers deep at this point he's like
uh he's he's too much of a wild car I
don't think he'll make it I was like
sitting right next to him so I was like
chucking a pair of them like yeah you
got it
I mean we had become friends after that
yeah but my initial time partying I
literally talk [ __ ] on me yeah yeah he
also beat up a paper towel dispenser
near my hometown whenever he was in the
league he got a public intoxication for
beating up the towel dispenser at a gas
station I mean yeah he won hard Jeffrey
went hard he was hard always been nice
to me too except for that first set for
that one what he didn't know I was there
so I I don't have any qualms with him it
wouldn't be Jeff Reed Matt Prater has
some legendary stories and he
to me with that moment on that Packers
Lions game where he threw a touchdown
which I absolutely loved and then you
got to go on an epic rant where the
brain was just spitting [ __ ] oh the
words were falling out Fox executives
like I've never cared about of this
before in my life is incredible laughter
you would think they were done I
would've got a job opportunity but yeah
after that but I didn't the yeah and
then we went we trended number one on
Twitter for like three hours it was 32
suck overall the NFL action with a
meaningless week 17 32 nothing game
Aaron Rodgers has heard on literally the
second play where I had Aaron Rodgers by
the way Hyde Aaron Rodgers lines in
commentary already already oh man I was
I was we were discount double checking
all over that goddamn thing and then
second play of the game he gets hurt so
I love Matt Prater what are the best
Matt Prater stories you've heard that
are not gonna get him in trouble I mean
I think we just all know this there's no
reason for me to tell any of those but I
appreciate my operator I wouldn't want
to ruin that moment we had yeah party
moment I'm going with Sebastian
Janikowski strictly because the Polish
Canon I've heard legendary tales there's
people and I haven't heard any good ones
you go out to TMZ like the TMZ there's
been numerous actresses in actors who've
been asked like who's the person has
been most wild your entire life and
they've party with like Motley Crue and
all these people in there like Sebastian
Janikowski is a lunatic of Wyatt
yeah well I was back for Twitter or
anything so him and Shane Locklear
roommates you should i shamelessly like
her you should go in the hall of fame if
he doesn't the people that are voting
for it don't understand football but he
I've heard legendary stories of them
having parties and just having like in
looking like the beaches of Normandy
like the day after where they have to
like get to practice where they're
walking over humans they've never met
before that's all just having a good
time sleeping on their couch wearing
like an outfit just like a fling in
Oakland to like yeah like insane he's
really good so it's like anybody that
can do that and do that I like my moment
that I realized I was a jenna Kowski fan
was after I was arrested and I was in
the substance of abuse policy program
which means you get tested eight times a
month and I got tested eight times a
month for 27 months holy crap yeah the
NFL substance of nose daddy so why not
clean if they saw a picture of me
drinking it was an automatic $15,000
fine I mean they came down on me hard
mostly because I called the head doctor
of that like I questioned his doctor
ship whenever he told me I'd do it for
24 months after a three-month trial so
it's 27 months altogether was like we've
decided to move you to Phase two I was
like I didn't know anything wrong in
phase one then why am I gonna face -
he's like well just reading your report
I believed 24 more months of this will
be yeah and I was like what type of
doctor are you anyways and he was like
I'm a psychologist so I was like is that
even a real doctor and then I got
punished for 27 months or 24 like
yelling back at a judge yeah exactly
- life sentence oh yeah great hammer you
know week you know oh three I've said
yeah exactly what happened so
unbelievable and I felt I feel like they
want you to get in the program well once
you get in they never want you to get
out they make it very difficult to get I
got out by the way succeeded Hey look at
me graduate I'm a graduate of the rock I
smoked some spice there for a couple
months early and that was a bad time but
I mean I got through it and yeah proud
of you ah so we played the Oakland
Raiders in Oakland when Janikowski was
there and LeClair was there in warm-ups
and this was after I got in trouble so I
was in the program you know so Jankowski
was a big was what's good man you know
cuz he's got like an accident like hey
man you're allegedly you know I love you
you took heat off me you know everybody
thinks I'm drunk or whatever I'm like oh
yeah I was like this program is a
nightmare dude I got a every time I
leave India and I got a call give them
an address I'm gonna be at two phone
numbers to reach me was like you have a
Pio so they they could test me or
whatever he's like oh go on cruise what
they do land on boat I was like oh my
god he's a guy I did it two years to go
on cruise I see you there I'm like you
are a hero here he's like I got you
shakes my hand walks away and I'm like
Janikowski just got me out of the worst
time in my life wow did you curse yeah
couple I was going over an old you love
oh my god I was cruising all over the
place I was in Morocco wait wait the
system yes I wanted a new random boat
the Pat McAfee NFL booze cruise only a
pluck only applicable to guys that are
on the program there's a lot of guys in
that program too I mean was that why
Kronk had a cruise I only run it half
the boat so I think if we hindsight
50/50 like Cam Newton says for that
grunt cruise we probably get the entire
boat not just half the boat yeah I heard
that was an electric time I don't
drunks ever failed a test I only got in
because I got arrested for a drug or
alcohol-related charge but janakowski is
definitely legend legend dude go on Cruz
what they do land on both are you to be
as big as he was last year and to still
be doing it like what is it like from
someone that had to like you know
dedicate to the craft and you see this
guy no I just natural my weight my
weight fluctuation was pretty crazy too
I am but it wasn't to the point where
like the entire Internet was like take
this picture and make jokes about it
well I mean it's not like 4k cameras
have done anybody any favors you know
what I mean like we used to wear all
white Spanx basically the coats that was
basically oh yeah it was always anything
no so I used to just have to go in these
ridiculous crash diets like give me all
of the meth or whatever you guys have
that I can get this out of me
it was um what was that stuff that was
killing people it was a supplement that
you I forget the name of anthrax that
definitely was killing people I don't
know it was a supplement that workout
supplement there was some supplement I
would take like Hydroxycut there was
whose hydroxyl got the old junk and my
hands started shaking yeah it's like and
I gotta get off this the og Hydroxycut I
used to go into like a 14 day date with
before every single training camp
because I would have to lose like 15 20
pounds guys you must have been
insufferable just like I would lock
myself was like I would go into my own
little cave because I might be you guys
know the deal
I got to lose like 15 20 pounds but I
used to think that the more weight you
had the further the ball would go you
know a big ball you don't see any
homerun hitters from all eating a burp
for me yeah it was a hiccup situation I
just had I had a tea from downstairs was
interesting situation Howard Schultz put
it together two or three which one we go
three three I think you literally saved
my favorite one for last I knew it was
coming
I know it's three welcome to Monday
Night Football
whoo this was actually my favorite one
yeah I didn't know which one I just I
wrote numbers on them I didn't look
vitamins all right so I believe that we
have something special in this room
right now and what it is so Nick I'm
gonna need the music is a possible
Monday Night Football crew you and I
let's go and I'm ready to go at any time
me too here's the scene
Monday Night Football we're gonna be in
Green Bay it's going to be Patrick
mahomes Aaron Rodgers Kansas City Green
Bay both are 1500 let's go because if
we're gonna send our tape for Monday
Night Football let's show that we can
handle the big moment yeah it's looking
for the perfect record big moments is
all we handle you let me bring us in and
then I'll toss it to you and let's just
do the [ __ ] show you got it hey hey
welcome to the big time bub
Patrick mahomes Aaron Rodgers the snow
won't stop falling at Lambeau two MVPs
two undefeated teams one perfect record
on the line all tonight game of the year
only on Monday Night Football welcome
inside as always I might have left go
joined by my perfect partner Pat McAfee
Pat it's a special special night at hand
what do we have to look forward to well
patty my home's got a huge arm and an
explosive offense Andy Reid's looking to
blast through the wall like the kool-aid
man here at Green Bay Lambeau is a place
with legendary moments you think back to
Steve Sabol and NFL Films the frozen
tundra and nothing could be as exclusive
and as elite as Monday Night Football
has tonight Aaron Rodgers looks to put a
cap on his legacy and take down the
young gun Patrick mahomes and have an
undefeated season nothing since there's
72 dolphins or the Packers gonna make a
run we'll find out right here in Lambeau
Green Bay Wisconsin it's gonna be an
amazing game the night Chiefs Packers
let's go down to our sideline reporter
Ed Helms who's gonna check in with the
coaching staff Thatta boy
Edie perfect how'd it feel oh good man
felt good doesn't this job [ __ ] nuts
the Internet or a commentary all of it
everything I like that you turn into
like a 1940's reporter when you do your
TV voice yeah you're it's a little bit
Howard Cosell but it's also like Mara
say the reporters are out for that the
dog bet the man I love it and I just got
to bring some juice now obviously the
people making it I don't know why ed
Helms was our sideline reporter I
couldn't think of a I know sideline
reporter I don't know who that is but I
know as you think I from the office Oh
what dude
yes exactly quarters crush so we'll
pitch this to Monday Night Football you
me Ed Helms on sideline the dummies
making the decision haven't pulled the
trigger I mean I sent out two tweets of
my people we trended for 10 hours about
it I haven't gotten the call I mean I
know I tried to get Nate Burleson on
there he said he'd be down so if it was
you me and Nate I think that'd be a
pretty [ __ ] tight group I'm a big fan
of toe drag swag Nate Burleson I think
he brings the heat man he bust his ass I
respect anybody that I go oh he's
working working yeah you know what I
mean a lot of people just get handed
stuff but that ain't us no not us dude
that ain't us no hey we're ready to get
our ass out there and find that [ __ ]
dog I think what we should I think what
we should do is just set up booths
outside of our the Monday Night Football
game is and if you want to watch a live
with the game with us we'll just mute it
we'll do the ceremonial muting of the
game and we'll just do a live event I
must call on the game but I would like
the ability to get the day before
interviews because a lot of my stuff
came from the day of what was that
experience like for you cuz to be in
there and it's usually like this stuffy
room with producers and you sit there
and they go what's been the issue on
third down Chuck so as soon as as soon
as we went to we did Green Bay first and
as soon as Aaron Rodgers opened the door
and saw me sitting in there he looked at
me to start laughing yeah that's [ __ ]
Joe Philbin and I got a massage in the
same room together in London whenever he
was coaching for the cult it's a big fan
so he was interim head coach when he
came in he just saw me and started
laughing you know and he said that's
amazing that people have that reaction
well Matt Patricia same thing so Matt
Patricia and Matthew Stafford by the way
teas and peas up for Kelly Stafford Matt
Stafford yes on white she's about to go
through some stuff Stafford was very
nice to me everybody just started
laughing as soon as I walked in there
I've as soon as they walked in there I
feel like the mood was heightened
because I was in there I feel like it
was I don't know your questions I just
wanted are they real
like when I interview I go I want to
learn some stuff I'm pretty intrigued
but people let's go back this goes back
to the daddy cigars you know I get
pretty I like to know why the greats are
great all right so that's something I
very much enjoy I like documentaries so
I asked
real questions that got some real Intel
out of it but also some other stuff you
know I said hard not saying all of the
Intel because you're supposed to keep it
private
hey I talk too much [ __ ] well we went
from Green Bay over to Detroit and then
I got a bunch of stuff here right and
like in my head yeah Green Bay is like
we really want to attack we think
they're really weak in the middle there
deal ID and then it Detroit's like we
think they're gonna attack the edge and
you're like oh my god just a heads up a
little bit different scheme coming at
you than you thought no it was I try to
do for me it was so cool because I was
back in an NFL building you know like we
went through the the walkthrough which
Green Bay runs an entire practice the
day before a game which I've never seen
before it was kind of interesting get to
see the field again and I had a lot of
friends are on the Packers so it was
nice to be back in there I respected the
profession I had no idea though that
those meetings really happened to the
extent that they happen because I was
never interviewed so it wasn't like I
didn't know how those really need punter
Intel yeah well they should have maybe
they learn a little bit more about the
game but like the I didn't know how
those meetings were supposed to go so it
was just like all right I'm all wrong
with this year let's see could you tell
it was weird between Aaron and McCarthy
did that come Karthi wasn't there I
remember Phil yeah but I just wasn't
sure if there was he had come on residue
oh it did come because like I note I
done has an article that's coming out
today that really dives into and so
check it out on Bleacher port like how
bad it got and I don't think either
parties like clean
well McCarthy so McCarthy is on a PR run
right now right he was doing yes
interviews this morning saying a lot of
things but I think anytime you got two
people together for 10 years I mean
that's a relationship that's still a
human relationship oh yeah and you're
talking about he goes and a lot of
success and a lot of money and a lot of
attention there's obviously a chance
that's gonna go bad but just like
Belichick and Brady like you just have
to be and bewilderment of how much
success they were able to bring to Green
Bay I think that's what I would like to
remember but I select did you say
bewilderment like that because it's a
SAT word oh gosh it's add your luck word
hey man that wasn't Andrew Luck we were
in it hey maybe I'm a card no a tree but
I I think it's I think it's actually
very ignorant of people to see that
situation go
they're together for ten years why would
they start fighting no have you ever
like if you read someone for ten years
that's a long day Hey
forevers a long time both of our brains
like good call back let's do it all
right last one
number two he still doesn't have any
missed the trash game I'll tell you why
it's why you're up under another kicker
hey I've been kicking footballs again by
the way I saw feel-good Pistons fire and
go really good before you open that do
you believe that if you kicked a man
square in the junk that you could kill
him I don't know I don't know the
physics or the science behind I just
feel like you running up full-speed
locked and loaded
might kill me I'm very confident that at
one point I had the strongest leg in the
world who that what year was that what
fine line mm there's probably like my
third or fourth maybe fifth year in a
league third through fifth
I just wrong it's like in a world I
think now I've always seen that like
really Jack guys they walk in any room
and they size people up were you just
like walking in looking at hamstrings
Cosman no they knew those people knew he
knew I mean I kick the soccer ball here
in 24 miles an hour at one point just
sitting still like from a standstill
I felt very good yeah it's on the
Internet what do you think about say
Kwan's legs
I think say Kwan's legs are next level
next level if he really tried to be a
kicker are those legs that could be like
super powerful is that an 80 yard field
goal I don't know how his leg speed is I
mean obviously with those quads would be
good but legs beats a big deal oh no it
hips knees knees hips the whole thing
yeah you got to really be able to move
it's an explosive extra nice try it when
I try and kick a field goal i total
by the way you should if thank you if
you don't know how to kick so don't even
[ __ ] around cuz you're gonna miss just
the toe thing is yes I just pray that it
goes straight what's a higher
consistency for sure for people at
laymen's that don't know how to kick in
that style yeah yeah that's smart like
somebody came I always like I used to
try and like come up and like put my
foot down I pour the [ __ ] knows yeah cuz
you don't know how to do it no you
should go to the people that don't know
how to kick in a soccer ball or a soccer
style like never done it before if
they're in for like a $10,000 field goal
kick or something like that toe it toe
that thing yeah and just try to go
straight up through it just go straight
up through flex mark half an inch below
way through the ball Oh like a half-inch
blow yeah and just follow straight
through to the center of the upright and
it should go well $10,000 from dr.
pepper coming your way or you can just
chest pass that thing into a hole in a
football the worst all right last one
it's bad game move it back have them
throw it let's make them do something
like they should also be like Tom Rhett
for their for why are you standing
there's ref I don't know I don't know
why I like watching people do the what's
it called with the basket pop a shot I
like watching people being really good
at that hey that um I do they got like
60 in a minute that Asian fella yo the
one the double hands Carson Edwards from
Purdue oh yeah
that's unbelievable number two the final
one yeah
who wins an NFL Royal Rumble so over the
top rope are the rules of NFL Rumble
obvious everybody knows that
WrestleMania this weekend check it out
yeah and how can we watch you during
WrestleMania this worked out that like
the plug can kind of is nice it's almost
like I saw through your piece of paper
and knew what was coming
okay so what do you do how can we watch
you are you gonna be doing like a free
show
well not appreciate so if I pay for the
pay-per-view I get to see you yeah but
you just get the network for free oh
yeah yeah for new subscribers so it's
free for new subscribers I'll be on
there you get it for 30 days so you get
you get WrestleMania for free which is
normally like $70 for before we get into
this NFL Royal Rumble yeah
how crazy is it to be a part of the WWE
it's absolutely insane there are the
only people that have really shown any
type of Hope in me you don't agree
Michael Cole has called me I mean like a
big fan of yours dude I like what you do
with yeah we'd like you start doing and
then the relationship started from just
a pre-show to now I make internet
content was there a meeting ever where
you're sitting across from Vince McMahon
no Vince McMahon I shook hands one time
it was low and then he walked away so
were you ever across from like Triple H
yeah Triple H and I text not our regular
basis like once every other week there
will be like a text message I gave my
little brother so many pedigrees I got
so many in-school suspensions all the
[ __ ] DX
hey no stitches were never they suspend
you what do you do know I would
that's a night if your smell a little oh
yeah so it's got to be cool to work with
yeah triple H is that guy and Michael
Cole is awesome was that your era of
wrestling too yeah yeah bad suitor
absolutely I I kind of drifted away from
it up for a while of course but to get
back into it and and they let me do
whatever I want really it's really nice
of that Michael Kors like just don't
swear we just want you to do whatever
you need to do how good are the athletes
incredible they're it's like Cirque de
Soleil but they're on they're on the
road 270 to 300 days a year so they're
putting on any Cirque du Soleil shows
while driving for three hours in the
middle of the night with no it's just
I once you see behind the curtain and
you like watch what these athletes are
doing yes the women are in Grantham it's
just it's next level and I just get to
talk [ __ ] the entire time I went to an
NXT event yes is like a year or two ago
let's go and it was in Madison Square
Garden like the theater and I walk in
and I was like I don't know any of these
[ __ ] are I'm with Matt Camp
who's like really big into wrestling and
I was like I'm gonna figure out my
favourite up-and-coming NXT wrestler
tonight and we're gonna we're gonna I'm
gonna be all about can I guess yeah
ricochet no no this is a little this
like two years ago
so we're watching and like Roode comes
out and like everyone's singing the song
and everyone's getting excited and I was
like hey he's okay
my number one guy was the [ __ ]
drifter and is this is before I'm
telling you this before because I'm
watching from an NFL perspective yeah
and he stand there and just hopped up on
the top turnbuckle I go
he's more explosive than all these
[ __ ] yeah you just hate him cuz
he's [ __ ] corny and he's singing these
songs so I'm in the bathroom and I'm I'm
waiting in line at Madison Square Garden
and I'm sitting there and I go I don't
know man I think The Drifter is my
favorite [ __ ] wrestler in NXT and then
as that's happening a producer of bleach
reports sees me goes Adam and comes up
and for some reason hugs me why the band
not pee I'm like in the line road code
road code no how again don't know
physical contact in the in the urinals
come on and this guy turns around goes
the [ __ ] drifter guys giving hugs in
the bathroom what the [ __ ] are you doing
here and I was like alright I'm gonna go
yeah I guess at that time saying Elijah
was good
Elias a lot my best say analyzed
st. Elias is good people are like he's
corny as [ __ ] I was like I don't know I
see something man you want to you want
to hear something crazy it's really
gonna blow your mind
Elias went to my high school stop
yeah like best friends with one of the
guys that's in that green room right now
like really high school yeah yeah
Lifeson I have known each other a long
time and now it's like it's hitting yeah
he's the guy Oh Corey graves who's the
commentator for both shows went to the
school right next to mine what the hell
is going on in your neighborhood hey man
we got good water over there bad
teachers bad teachers but we got good
water over there but yeah lice literally
graduated high school I've known him
he's an athlete was he bald in high
school he was a tiny little stick Wow he
was a tiny little stick and he made this
decision I go back to I was at West
Virginia and I would go back to
Pittsburgh where everyone my family's
from to party sometimes you know and I
walked in this house party and I had I
had a good time in college and I was in
the kitchen as soon as I walked in and
it was exactly like you would think like
as soon as I walk in somebody has a beer
bong ready for me they're like hey you
ready to go up like absolutely so I
welcomed home well yeah it's great to be
here you know okay great see everybody
eyeballing this beer I put it down and
hand it back I'm like all right let's
get it and I turn to my right and Elias
who wasn't named Elias at the time was
holding like a gallon of water like a
jug of water right and he had like these
little pre-made meals that he had to eat
like every two hours through the night
now as a four meal prepping was the
thing wrong with you what are we doing
here and he's like oh man I'm trying to
become professional wrestler I can pull
my body up or whatever I'm like okay
let's go and we got in like a good
probably 40 remember this is I just did
a beer bong right in front of his face
ie probably and see me in like a year
since I went to West Virginia and we had
a 45-minute conversation he was like
yeah I'm gonna give it a go I'm really
focused in doubt him like it pays if
you're doing that I'm gonna try to get
the NFL but what that being said I'm I'm
gonna grab that beer bong again and see
if we can really do some stuff but he
alive unbelievable Isis once my high
school year that was completely random I
did not research that all right I have
names of people in the NFL that I find
to be the biggest strongest so I feel
like I'm gonna say a name and in Royal
Rumble fashion the next one that comes
in you just tell me who gets thrown out
and who
still alive okay yeah yeah first guys
gonna be Aaron Donald let's go he's the
first two that runs into the ring I
don't know what his entrance song is
Aaron Donald is in the ring he trains
with knives fake knives [ __ ] is it
really yeah was fake you to know that he
went to school right next to mine as
well
dude Pittsburgh Marino Terry Brad
graduate high school
Darrelle Revis they weren't friends but
graduate high school
next comes in as Fletcher Cox who's
still in the ring
Aaron Donald's owner he got a 10 pack he
posted that photo the other day it's
outrageous he's a little bit tired
defensive tackle from the Ravens Brandon
Williams comes in you're not gonna know
all these guys it's okay he's a nose
tackle yeah he's gonna be tough to get
out there but I think Aaron Donald
trained so hard with real knives he
kicks him out almost as soon as he gets
in there San Francisco 49er defensive
lineman DeForest Buckner at six foot
eight never heard of him like his name
he's tall which means the leverage of
Aaron Donnell which is what Aaron
Donald's good at gets him out number one
seed is still a so Aaron Donald has now
gone through Fletcher Cox Brandon
Williams - Forrest Buckner his abs are
pulsating his pecs are bouncing he's
going who's next
Oh Goldberg yeah greatest Jewish athlete
of all time
Khalil Mack runs into the ring
Khalil Mack is now facing off with a
tired Aaron Donald yeah that's why I put
Aaron down little one because where's
Jeong Runa Jon Gruden is sitting in the
booth with Mark Davis getting a fresh
bowl cut okay so they getting haircuts
yeah 90 million guaranteed a lot of
money man that's what that's what Jon
Gruden said shortly after signing a
hundred million now I think this is
where Kaleo Mack could potentially great
battle to someone else enter the ring
while they're fighting I think it lasts
long enough that then another person
comes in Washington defensive lineman
great wrestling name Doron pain love
that name - Ron pain - Ron's five 300
320 guy
Kaleo Mac Aaron Donald they're battling
battling they hear old pain cuz he come
in they started the poutine that's what
they say before he runs in yeah anything
else yeah that's it it's kind of a dead
moment they need a little cheap pop
fireworks pop OH
Kaleo mac and Aaron Donald oh yeah
realize what they're doing okay they
stop they turn to the
Gazi liens and they toss pain out
flipped him over he's gone you're gonna
snark at this but I'm gonna give you the
next one next one is Bengals defensive
lineman Andrew Billings known because he
broke Mark Henry's lifting record that
Mark Henry when he was in high school so
this is a short stocky 511 6 foot
300-pound power lifter that beat the
strongest man in the world Mark Henry
he runs I beat him money he was in high
school that was world strongest boy mark
n write it down I gotcha
yeah draw this man let's take it as you
can tell I like my Andrew Billings so he
runs in he's got good leverage oh yeah
that kind of Murray size or Mac and
Donald now teammates now I think I think
Aaron Donald and Billings because they
got the low leverage thing they turn on
Kaleo Mac tired Khalil Mac yes Aaron
Donald decides he's won enough in life
eliminates himself ocassi Billings is
now hanging out by himself the little
spark plug of a man who beat world's
strongest boy Mark Henry in runs miles
Garrett from the Cleveland Browns well
let's go Dog Pound miles we prep toss is
that little spark plug out on wind yeah
one-hand like a like a hip yeah yeah
yeah and then comes quitting Nelson just
like an 80s rock song wearing a bandanna
walking like the bushwhackers yeah yeah
holding like a two-by-four yeah yeah
Quentin Nelson wins that thing okay it's
that guy up probably who isn't happy
about anything that guy said or looked
at him just from personal experience
that's where I would say and he tossed
his old 300 pound spark plug cuz he over
the top rope ladies and gentlemen it's
not over there's four more people Marcus
hunt of the Indianapolis Colts who you
know is [ __ ] enormous he's a massive
maze like six nine three forty and it's
quick Nelson's teammates yeah he sees
Quentin Nelson he gets in he jumps out
he also eliminates himself Wow there's
two competitors who have eliminated
themselves but still got the paycheck
what you have to respect the business
sense coleus Campbell of the
Jacksonville Jaguars and Chris Jones
defensive lineman of the Chiefs running
at the same time well that's cheating so
we're gonna have to question their moral
code I've party with coleus a couple of
times good guru got a very interesting
voice he may have
in the prototype for an avatar that guy
he's a freak athlete that's all I think
Quentin Nelson handles that situation on
bull chokes because he's pissed off
about them attempting to cheat aah
so he takes on the double team like a
real gentleman Quentin Nelson ends up
your winner mr. program elf dumb oh the
Undertaker dumb tailor LaJuan comes in
Oh with Undertaker's music top-hat
dressed like Boss Hogg don't steams
coming up stings in the rafter it's not
gonna come down just gonna watch the
show thinking about it
Taylor Lewan comes in Taylor won't wanna
quit Nelson just had a viral video they
were imitating yeah already being offset
thank you yeah I said take off but so
they're friends yeah but they have to
fight each other
and I would say that Taylor's already
rich like he's much more wealthy than
Quentin right this exact although
Quentin's gonna be much more wealthy
than him in a couple years so I would in
my mind I would be like well rich Taylor
is just gonna be like you know I don't
wanna go against a friend here I'll also
eliminate myself but he's an offensive
lineman so that would be quite a
question to write these other guys that
have self eliminated our D lineman yeah
and they've already done enough they all
the guys didn't limit himself they've
already done enough you know Marcus hunt
did it strictly because he doesn't wanna
face off against ghosts again cuz he's a
good teammate good good locker room yeah
Taylor the one though I don't know cuz
he's fresh Terrell Owens fresh it's kind
of attitude but Quentin Nelson doesn't
seem to have many feelings you know I
don't have a much feelings he doesn't
even realize that he and Taylor were
friends when he gets in there I think
Taylor has a personality he's still he's
like hey man we just did the Mexico
thing I think before he even gets his
hat off that incredibly nice hat that he
was before that thing even gets off and
quit Nelson's already ended it and
Taylor's the one walks out of there with
bags of cash in a situation where a
friend of his that he thought turned his
back on him and that friend is now the
NFL Royal Rumble champ so you got to
respect it a little bit he probably
collapse goes off back to Mike for
Abel's town and has a good time
congratulations to quit Nelson for
winning the NFL Royal Rumble hey no
friend of your show I can't believe that
you didn't have a good
with them next time you want to
interview them tell I'll call in
I'll be like quitting it's ok it was bad
yeah he had no idea who I was anything
who would win a Royal Rumble of only
quarterbacks the Cam Newton the names
that I came up with that were in the
final four were cam Josh Allen mahomes
and I feel like Big Ben would be like
scrappy like all of a sudden like a
chair flies in yeah that's grabbing it
by the yes
Big Ben Roethlisberger's grabbing that
chair hitting somebody with it yeah and
then he's throwing the person who threw
the chair in under the bus a hundred
percent but he's gonna put up elite in
them so who wins are those for Josh
Allen Cam Newton mahomes and Big Ben
let's remember let's what's it say this
is a guy still Royal Rumble rules but
they're all for the reform an ROI yeah
let's go with let's remember the grit
factor here cam has not climaxed this
month cam is usually no sex no I'm no
personal yet that whole thing a lot of
pent-up frustration so we got to think
about that yeah he also crashed his
truck pretty nasty in survived and got
out Wyatt yeah and got out of it yeah
ben roethlisberger they'll crash the
Hayabusa in the middle of downtown
Pittsburgh what yeah I don't remember
this Scott is like if they thought it
was big deal like this was before I
think this is before tour like in his
first couple years Wow Ben
Roethlisberger also has a lot of history
with WWE he's been in a ring before so
that might help him now so the gritty
old Big Ben might help him out here
because he is I mean we've all seen him
try to avoid pass rushers does not exist
and he just takes that thing and throws
the rock
Josh Allen he's a little bit too young
and happy I think he's just excited to
be there in the moment you got to get
the old grill Holmes is like a Bret the
Hitman Hart
he's like a show he's like an athlete
you know I don't know I was guys where I
didn't have anything else I really
thought you were going somewhere there I
was excited to hear it
I think mahomes gets eliminated like the
rock he's gonna try to do something
fancy he's gonna try to go up to the top
rope yes because he's an athlete yeah
and bravas burgers probably just gonna
stumble and just knock him off he's a
little
Josh Allen's gonna be so bright I love
the idea that Big Ben accidentally
knocks everybody else out yeah I think
that's what's gonna happen then if we
really start looking at the film here in
our brains watch the video I think
Roethlisberger probably wins it just by
like stumbling fumbling bumbling his way
into the championship and then I am
newton stuff to bet against I feel like
if it was all quarterbacks Eli would be
the first one eliminated
I feel like Baker would actually be the
more Sean Andrew Luck would hop over the
rope as soon as it started I don't like
conflict right guys good luck out there
Nick Foles would be coming to Val Venis
as music hello ladies and I feel like
Kirk Cousins is Kurt Angle but like with
muscles
I don't think Kurt Angle deserve that oh
you thought it was insulting Kurt Angle
I think so Kurt Angle Kurt Angle rises
up in the biggest moments he want to go
meddle with a broken frickin neck bro
remember that I like Kirk Cousins
business sense he's more like a business
yeah I think he's a business and then
who would win a kicker punter Royal
Rumble I feel very good if I was in
there I'm not though I'm retired yep I'm
gonna kick for the XF Oh No
if the exit felt called Pat and said we
need big-name pop hold on you're a WWE
employees yeah potential microphone
usage their potential I don't know I
haven't been throwing anything but you
would think the AFL offered me a job to
compensate the day after I signed with
the WWE big paycheck to they'd offer me
a big paycheck to do it you know what
I've never got paid no would have never
got paid but he will so you'll be doing
XFL stuff I don't know about Monday
Night Football well it's okay we'll just
you know we have a tape we can we can
repurpose this yeah we can for XML
welcome to excel Sonny Jurgensen z--
grandson taking on Jack Nicholas's
nephew next on EXIF I think the XFL will
succeed cuz they got good business sense
in there Oliver Luck running the show
the AFL is gonna be a wild story that's
going on for I've heard I've got some
DMS from a lot of old teammates I were
in there they said it was a complete
[ __ ] show everything was a [ __ ] show
like a joke like fire festival type
stuff like no I mean they didn't get a
pay rate for the first cover game meal
is like Kraft Kraft cheese and ham and
the cheese is still in the wrapper
I mean I heard it like I think this
documentary that's gonna come out about
it obviously at some point if someone's
gonna make something I mean did they not
have any money for the first week like
what happened how do you not make
payroll first week like what is that
even know Billie McFarland's in their
[ __ ] stir in a pot I met somebody
that went to fire festival I was very
jealous actually I wanted the experience
a guy that's part of my crew
his name's Diggs yeah he's an Italian
Anthony to kill you he was all about
that type of thing like being influenced
by influencers love it and he heard
about it saw the orange picture and he
was like I want to go we almost expensed
it like on the set I mean hindsight I
wish you would have done it amazing
incredible
I appreciate coming in can I read one
thing that I got from a fan that I
didn't expect to get so I got this
package from Stu Resnick out in Phoenix
Arizona alright still appreciate you Stu
and he ends up that he's a grandpa that
listened to the show a lot let's go and
he wrote me this awesome message where
he talked about that when he heard me at
the end of the podcast where I was
talking about I'm an Eagles fan they won
the Super Bowl and I started getting
emotional thing about my family he's
like it [ __ ] hit me and he wrote me
this awesome letter and I'm not gonna
read the whole thing but him and his 11
year old grandson playing catch and he
listened to the show and he said that we
rekindled a long-lost appreciation of
football for him and that he thanks us
for that this he had a license plate he
was a personalized license plate he
traveled with him for the last year he
doubt that anyone took notice of the
numbers that's exactly how he wanted it
but I know for sure that I knew what it
means and I opened it up and I knew
within 20 seconds this is an Eagles
thing I'm just gonna show it and it made
me realize one how football fans can all
be connected to each other over some
craziness the numbers are six to three
zero eight eight nine I was just trying
to do the tt9 text there you know and I
turned it upside is that a TV B's yeah
Jason Kelsey snap the ball to Cory
Clement and toss the ball to Trey Burton
who threw it to Nick Foles
for Philly Philly so to you i Stu I'm
gonna put this in the studio if you're
still listening it's officially in there
for
here on out I appreciate you sending
that to me and the awesome note
mentioned on all the great old Eagles
like Tommy McDonald thank you dude
you're the [ __ ] man I don't know if
you curse in your household but now we
do shut up Vince Macaulay - OH honestly
awesome bartender I went on quite a Mark
Wahlberg or any other day just watching
[ __ ] yeah just like friends invincible
and then there was another one he did
where he shot some people and it was
crazy I appreciate you coming on thanks
for have fun I did a great time you have
a really cool fans though - they're the
[ __ ] they're the homies hey you deserve
it man I'm happy for you dude so the
homies as I like to call them the 33%
Pat gave his 33% check out everything
Twitter is at Pat McAfee doesn't matter
you know he shits everywhere no no
they're too much of me is too much of me
my mom's already given up Jim followed
me a week ago appreciate you dude thank
you hear the man Wrestlemania Sunday
check it out will do